hi conan my name is marie i'm calling
from saskatchewan canada
my question for you kind of a
two-part question because
there's
i thought there was or heard there was
no rules about that
but i haven't listened to all your
podcasts i'm not sure maybe if you've
talked on the subject before but
i was wondering your favorite type of
genre for music as well
my true question is if you were an
instrument
what would you choose to be bearing in
mind
uh
extremities that the other the person
playing you would be using um
whether or not it's fingers toes
your mouth
um
yeah anyways
i uh
really interested in knowing
if you were to choose to be
an instrument what that might be
enjoy your day
i love it when someone leaves what's
clearly a very erotic and suggestive
message
and then says enjoy your day
you know
that's my favorite part yeah yeah you
could be ice cream and someone was
licking you
what would it feel like in which part of
your body would be the ice cream well
anyway enjoy your day
if you need me you can reach me at
extension 3254.
oh man uh
wow uh marie this is quite the message
first of all i'll start with the genre
of music i would say the genre of music
that just grabs me by my uh nether
region
and electrifies me has always been
hardcore rockabilly music
you know that about me i do i used to um
in college i discovered the uh elvis sun
session recordings you know when he's
just getting started out and uh he's
recording that's all right mama
and uh blue moon in kentucky
and uh these different baby let's play
house and then at debt spilled over into
all this other um rockabilly music that
i loved and it got me interested in
combing my hair up so that it looked
insane and i grew up my sideburns and i
learned to play the electric guitar
and i love that kind of yodelly singing
yeah
um you're good at it too well thank you
yeah i think i
i have the feeling i don't know why but
i almost become
some tennessee
you know uh rockabilly cat sometimes
yeah and i uh i really love that stuff
so that's my that's my jam
instrument that had an i i had an
obvious answer for that one for you or
for conan i felt like she was obviously
suggesting the cello i mean you're in
someone's crotch right no no that's is
that what she said if you could be an
instrument yeah you would want to be a
cello so you could be in someone's
crotch well that's where you went oh um
i think she there's also an oral way
that you can go
there are instruments that people
blow into
clarinet wait excuse me what did you say
david like a flute what's wrong with you
you sick what is wrong with you that's
gross we don't need to get into that
david what so you started it i did not
yeah you did
i did yeah i just yeah
everybody was thinking it no the flute
you're blowing on you're blowing on the
side and you're making these d that's
not
i want to de-sex this as much as i can
why that's the best part of this
question
is this this is what she wanted out of
this so you're thinking it would be fun
to be the cello because you're down in
someone's crotch yes
oh my god you're the mother of two
you're the mother of twins sona you've
got to clean up your act now i
you could still be a cello and be
someone's mom
no one's ever said that before
that's one of those sentences i've never
heard before no but what are you
thinking like a like a like a sax well
help me out here david there's another
way to go which i think she was sort of
suggest am i wrong was she not
suggesting something sexual when she
said remember toes parts of your body
your extremities extremities you think a
woodwind instrument
um something where mouth is on tube
there's some blowing
that's what she's implying am i crazy to
think that no that's what she was
implying right which is why my answer is
a 1971
moog synthesizer
wow yeah yeah that's the answer that she
doesn't expect that is not sexy this is
one of those times where if gorly was
here he'd be like oh good answer yeah
and we're here and not out having his
fez blocked
um
[Laughter]
at the local uh niche hipsteratorium
um
he would say like oh yeah
that right the 1972
moog synthesizer that was the one the
who
used on
uh baba o'reilly you know okay yeah
how is that going
you know but isn't that
remember that cool sound from another
one is uh won't get fooled again
wow
[Music]
um
apologies to everyone
uh
i don't know what happened there but
that
the beginning of won't get fooled again
and uh i know
the moog synthesizer parts by heart
anyway
shout out to the who hope you guys are
well
um
that's what i'm doing listening right
now i think you and i'm quite certain
that townsend is listening and he's a
big fan and so is
all right i don't know about that
yeah that's my impression that's a good
one this is my coded impression
impression
please please pay attention to me i
might have too many siblings and nobody
paid attention
neither of these sound like each other
[Music]
i had twins and my husband knows karate
i'm conan i can't be more irish
literally i can't even try to be more
irish that's actually a very good
impression
you nailed me there